So far, we have talked about the case where there was an error in
the knowledge or an error in the reasoning or in the learning. The knowledge for
example was incorrect in some way but the knowledge can also be incomplete.
There can be a gap in knowledge or in reasoning or in learning. A gap in
knowledge occur when we're doing this exercise under explanation-based learning.
In that particular case, the agent had build this part of the explanation, and
it also had this part of the explanation. But it could not connect these two,
because there was no knowledge to connect that are object that has thick
sides and it can limit heat transfer that it would protect against heat.
Once the agent detects this as a knowledge gap,
then it can set up a learning goal. The learning goal now,
is, acquire some knowledge that will connect these two pieces of knowledge.
Once the agent detects a knowledge gap, it can set up a learning goal.
The learning goal now is to be able to connect these two pieces of information.
Notice that we are seeing how agents can spawn goals.
In this particular case the agent is spawning a learning goal.
You might recall that when we did this exercise on explanation based learning,
the agent went back to its memory, and found a precedent, found a piece of
knowledge, that enabled it to connect these two parts of the explanation. And so
this link was formed and the agent was then able to complete its explanation.
This is an example how the learning goal was satisfied, using some piece of
knowledge. In this case the knowledge came from the memory. But the agent could
have potentially also acquired the knowledge from the external world.
For example, it may have gone to a teacher and said, I have a learning goal.
Help me with the knowledge that will satisfy that learning goal.
Its ability to spot learning goals and then find ways of satisfying or achieving
those learning goals or any goal in general, is another aspect of metacognition.
So this was an example of how metacognition helps resolve a gap in knowledge.
Now let us see how it can help resolve gaps in reasoning or
learning. To see how metacognition can help resolve reasoning gaps,
let us return to this example of using mean sense analysis in
the blocks micro build. Once the agent reaches a cul de sac in the reasoning.
The agent could formally list its goal and ask itself how can I help to
resolve this cul-de-sac. It may then be the reminder of this strategy problem
reduction was it uses its goals into several independent goals and
then the agent can go about achieving each goal at one at a time. Thus in this
example, the agent set up a new reasoning goal and that used that reasoning goal
to pick a different strategy and thereby achieved that reasoning goal.
Note also that this is one way in which we can integrate multiple strategies. We
first use some [x] analysis right in the cul-de-sac, form a new listening goal,
use the listening goal to bring in a different strategy follow reduction and
then go back to the original strategy means and
analysis. We're achieving each goal independently